- [Ralph] I got a call from an agent
who wanted me to go and
audition for a new film
called the Empire Strikes Back.
That was how I became a Stormtrooper.
- [Female Narrator]
This whole thing started
because this guy at our office
is really into Star Wars.
We all have one, right?
After some pretty serious
internet sleuthing,
I've tracked down this guy.
- [Ralph] My name's Ralph Morse.
- [Female Narrator] He was a Stormtrooper
in Star Wars episodes five and six.
That's the Empire Strikes
Back and Return of the Jedi.
- [Ralph] I was in the get-
my-shuffle ready sequence.
I decided to carry my gun
left-handed, side saddled,
like I was carrying a shotgun in the West,
and it's in the film.
You can see it.
- [Female Narrator] We're
talking about what it felt like
to be a Stormtrooper,
and, for the most part,
that means what it felt
like to wear the costume.
- [Ralph] I think all the
costumes were the same size,
and the original model, I
think, was about five foot 10.
Some of the guys who
were either terribly tall
or terribly short found
the costumes unbearable.
Once you're in this thing, you
can't really get out of it.
You couldn't really sit down at all.
You had to kind of lean to one
side, and, if you wanted
to go to the bathroom, you
needed to prepare yourself.
- Excuse me.
- [Ralph] You needed more
than 30 seconds warning.
- Please, can I?
Oh boy.
- [Female Narrator] Okay,
but there's the helmet,
the iconic helmet.
- [Ralph] The first helmet they gave me,
I couldn't see through
the damn thing at all.
The other problem we had were our boots.
They had soles, but they
had no tread in the soles,
so you would slide all over the place.
I don't know a Stormtrooper who hasn't,
at some point, fallen over.
- [Female Narrator] Alright,
so it wasn't very glamorous,
but it's still cool, right?
'Cause, you know, Star Wars.
(playful music)